my dad had an expression he said don't
tell me what you value
show me your budget i'll tell you what
you value so president joe biden has
released his budget plan for fiscal 2023
at the very moment we're experiencing
the highest inflation rates in 40 years
and it turns out he values
the same sort of government spending
that is already sending prices sky-high
you'd figure with covid receding debt
rising and a tidal wave of unfunded
liability staring us right in the kisser
biden would take the opportunity to
radically reset the federal government's
balance sheet instead his budget plan
could be called rearranging deck chairs
on the titanic the president wants to
spend 5.8 trillion dollars which would
include jacking spending on defense
education and police he talks about
levying a controversial and probably
unconstitutional wealth tax on
billionaires that will pay for it all
but he still expects a budget deficit of
1.2 trillion dollars if your gun attacks
unrealized capital gains president biden
at least spend it on something pretty
it's debt finance spending that spurs
inflation in the first place rather than
cutting spending and reforming
entitlements the government borrows and
prints money so it can keep giving
goodies to its favored citizens you get
more dollars chasing the same amount of
goods and that leads to price hikes
meanwhile at least a dozen states
california georgia hawaii and maine
among them are thinking about giving
residents money to spend on things like
gas the price of which has gone through
the roof so today we're announcing a 9
billion tax refund to tens of millions
of californians doling out tax dollars
to alleviate the pain of inflation
caused by government spending is like
drinking a beer in the morning to ease
your hangover it's only setting up the
next binge fed chairman jerome powell
has announced a series of interest rate
hikes to help tame inflation but in a
recent speech he made no mention of the
increase in the money supply measured by
m2 which is risen by a record 41 in two
years or of the federal reserve's
holding of u.s debt which has jumped 3.5
trillion dollars over the same time
period
and as interest rate hikes will be small
enough that it's unclear they'll have
much impact back in the 1980s fed
chairman paul volcker allowed the fed
funds rate to more than double in less
than two years time to over 20 percent
that helped kill inflation but it also
caused the most severe recession since
the great depression worse serious hikes
by the fed today will not just likely
cause a major economic downturn they
will devastate the government's balance
sheet requiring either massive tax hikes
on everyone huge reductions in
government services or a combination of
both according to recent conservative
estimates from the congressional budget
office as the federal budget grows the
cost of paying interest on the debt will
keep increasing until it accounts for
about 24 cents of every dollar spent by
2050
and that assumed interest rates would
remain historically low so even moderate
increases in the fed's fund rate would
push the cost of servicing the debt much
higher causing the government to borrow
more money kicking us into a vicious
cycle of economic despair we're reducing
the size of the deficit
relative our economy by almost
two-thirds
reducing inflationary pressures and
making real headway cleaning up the
fiscal mess i inherited joe biden can
talk a good game about fiscal
responsibility but it's clear he doesn't
understand why prices are going up and
his policies will keep them high for the
foreseeable future that might cost him
and the democrats control of the house
and the senate in the fall perhaps the
white house in 2024 that'll be too bad
for him and his party but his
unwillingness to confront massive
spending and debt is gonna cost all of
us a lot more than that